Five,
four,
three.
Welcome everybody to the are podcast,
Gazebo experienced.
Guys,
would you take a minute and please join
me under the Gazebo of course,
referencing to our new age three video
that I hope everyone enjoyed the cat
fish market.
God bless you all.
Thank you to today.
Our sponsors are Robin Hood Express,
Vpn and honey and I thank you all for
joining us on this beautiful,
splendid blessing.
Friday.
We are truly blessed to be enjoying a
Friday together.
God,
you know,
I saw one time I was at a store and
someone in the checkout lady and she
says to me,
have a blessed day and I was like,
I don't believe in God,
but I just love that I have a blessed
day.
Like damn,
like good day.
No bless it.
That's pretty nice.
I was taught like the idea that God and
all of his infinite power and wisdom was
like this day is a blessed for you,
for you and only you.
I love that.
Not only you,
we're all blessed to have a blessed day.
I just love it.
So I have a bloodstained Friday.
Everyone.
We've got a lot to talk about.
We're talking about better help.
A lot of controversy there.
We are talking about there's been a
story that Lacroix Popular Sodie pop
drink,
which of which I'm a big fan,
is being sued for putting cockroach
poison in their drinks.
Sounds a little far fetched.
Horrible,
but is it.
Let's find out.
We're going to take a deep dive.
We've also got up a Kanye West,
the great Kanye West a had a meeting
with Donald Trump that has got a lot of
people talking and so much more today on
the.
Join me under the Gazebo.
Would you please experience.
So let's start from the over in the
Gazebo.
Let's start from the top.
You're better help.
Okay.
Now better help.
I think that there's a lot of
misconceptions going around.
I'm not,
we're going to take a deep dive.
We've also.
Oh no,
that wasn't going the whole time.
Was it?
Okay,
good.
I'm not using my laptop is also right.
Right.
Okay.
Alright.
Where was that a Eli?
Can you throw me under the customer
better help?
Um,
there's been a lot of misconception
about I'm,
I'm,
I'm talking about my involvement with
better help.
Okay.
Um,
let,
let me start from the top.
Better help is a,
an online therapy service.
Okay.
Um,
um,
which they've sponsored one of our
podcast episodes a couple of months ago.
Okay.
Now a lot of youtubers have been getting
criticized lately for having put better
help reads on their videos about mental
health,
about them being depressed and such.
And a lot of people have been accusing
them of being predatory because they're
like,
oh,
I'm so depressed and here's better help.
They're accusing them of a exaggerating
their depression to sell better help or
to go to better help sponsor,
I don't know.
And then people started going through
their terms of service and found some
concerning things there as well of the
service itself.
In the terms of service.
There was something I,
I,
I don't remember exactly.
There was something like a,
they can't guarantee that your
conversations,
private stuff like that.
Like,
like,
you know,
weird stuff.
And so first of all,
I want to make clear,
okay.
First of all,
we had one sponsor with better help that
was two months ago and the topic of
mental health was not brought up in
association with our read at all and to
the best of my recollection,
I don't think that we even talked about
it in that episode and it predated our
update video when I talked about being
depressed by month a month at least.
Okay.
But here's where I think people got
thrown off because Pewdie pie made a new
video about it and he goes through the
terms of service and he points out a lot
of questionable things,
which is fine and he doesn't like the
service and he raises good points about
it,
but the way that he presented my
involvement in it I thought was a little
misleading and a little out of context
and it made it look like I was way more
involved with this company that I was.
Or even that it made it look like I used
my being depressed to somehow sell
better help.
So I want to show you guys if I could
please exhibit a.
It was.
This is beauty pies video.
Let me go back a little bit.
So here,
let's watch this.
So he goes on here and he's talking
about here.
I was just joking.
By the way guys,
everyone needs to sociopath enter the
code.
Shane,
for your cheaper online therapy to date,
I would never have guessed it was
actually this was the case.
So this leads to a lot of the sponsored
videos of these 100,
100 of Youtube ers being about mental
health,
which could actually be a good thing,
but they are made so that people sign up
for the website.
I'm Scott.
It's Scott from depression to
expression.
So he's saying there's all these you
tubers that are promoting better health
on videos about depression.
He has a problem with that.
He doesn't think that that's ethical.
So here's,
here's what he shows here.
If you're looking for anything to miss
out on,
don't miss out on this.
Welcome to expression.
Whoa.
I actually messed up there and
completely serious before we start.
I have so much respect for each and
every one of you for watching and being.
Why do you ask for my payment
information now?
Okay.
As we know have been in therapy,
I've been
just dealing with a lot of stuff that I
needed to deal with and I feel good
anyways.
I feel good.
That's what is that probably about so
you can access professional,
affordable and convenient counseling.
I just hit a wall where it was.
It has gotten so bad that it was
basically either stop making videos or
disappear.
Also,
this video is sponsored by better
health,
more information about that,
so the way it's cut makes it look like
my video.
My update video was sponsored by better
health and that's what I felt when I saw
it too.
Yeah,
and I thought it was.
I was like,
Whoa,
like why would that be there?
That gives totally the wrong impression
because I've never talked about better
health and depression.
Ever fact,
when I did the sponsoree two months ago,
I didn't even endorse the product
because I have never used the service.
We checked it to make sure we checked it
to make sure that within 24 hours a
therapist contacted us and they did.
So we did some due diligence in that
regard to test out the service,
but I never endorsed it.
I never said that I used it to treat my
depression either,
but it seemed.
But at any rate,
let me,
let me say,
focus on this.
Um,
that seems like the only reasonable
conclusion to make is that he's calling
me out,
which is,
I thought I was like,
Dude,
what the hell?
And I was,
I was pretty upset with him and I
contacted him directly and I was like,
hey man,
what,
why,
what's the deal?
And he says he didn't,
he didn't mean to make it look that way
and he made a comment trying to clarify.
But the people that read the comments
compared to the people that watched the
video is very small.
Okay.
So what happened here is that,
um,
Bobby Burns,
this youtuber here made a video about
depression that's sponsored by better
help and he uses my clip in it talking
about depression.
So here,
let me show you this anymore videos.
I just hit a wall where it was gotten so
bad that it was basically either stop
making videos or disappear forever.
So today's video is going to be about
youtube happiness.
We're get started.
Make sure you hit that notification.
Bell lets you know whenever I upload new
videos also,
this video is sponsored by Dell.
You'll notice that it's from bobby's
video,
but he cut out the context so to
understand either way because the part
in pdfs video,
it's just kinda like a super cut of
examples of like it doesn't really
inform the Butler affordable and
convenient counseling.
I just hit a wall but I think he did it.
He didn't do it on purpose but I just
want to clarify,
you know,
because it makes sense to us.
It didn't make a difference to make a
connection between being depressed and
then from a company we didn't want to do
that.
That's my personal choice that we made
so that it was kind of so.
And I think that [inaudible] who's the
biggest youtuber in the world talking
about this,
people take it seriously and it looks
like it.
I mean,
that's how I interpret it.
I could be wrong.
I talked to a lot of other people that
saw it that way too and it just seems
like.
But you can see that basically either so
they don't seem to know more information
about that at the end of this video.
So again,
then he goes on to to criticize,
criticize a lot of youtubers.
He also doesn't really criticize them
harshly,
is more criticizing this service of
better help names.
He names a lot of people and he shows a
lot of faces of people and you know,
when you're Pewdie Pie,
the effect of that is that.
Yeah,
he was,
he was very,
he was very tempered in his criticism.
He wasn't like coming out.
He was being very.
He was being very rational and fair
about it.
I mean,
I'm not saying,
but again,
I just want to clear that up that that
video was not in any way sponsored by
better.
Hell yeah.
We've only worked with them once so.
Okay.
But regardless of that,
I think it's pretty weird that bobby
used that clip anyway because I keep
seeing that clip going around of bobby
using my clip talking about depression,
but there's not a clear separation.
So people think that.
But that's not the case.
So let me just see here.
I've got so
in response to the criticism.
So first of all,
I just want to make that clear.
Okay.
Now in response to their,
I think that there was some implication
that anyone that works with better help
is negligent,
a shill or irresponsible or somehow
selling out their fans.
And even though I never mentioned
depression,
am I read,
I do disagree with that assertion.
I do personally disagree with that
assertion.
Now let me talk about this.
I'm not sure what.
First of all,
I'm not sure what I could do to vet them
more than I did.
I mean in a perfect world,
I liked the service.
It seems interesting and it seems like
it would be useful for a lot of people.
Like on face value.
It seems like a cool service.
They're owned by a publicly traded
company and they're one of the most
widely advertised services on the
internet across television,
radio,
podcasting,
and Youtube,
so with all the information available,
it's a perfectly rational decision to
think that it's a good useful service
and something that's good,
good to promote and I mean,
again,
these guys are going through the terms
of service and picking it apart and
there's weird questionable stuff in
there,
but I don't think like this.
It's a.
it's a weird standard to make that you
want the slit,
the expectation that anyone you ever
work with your reading,
the entire 20 page legal document of a
terms of service like I don't think
anyone.
Very few people in the history of
youtube have ever read the terms of
service and I'm willing to bet that if
they did read the terms of service,
they wouldn't want to work with them
because terms of service is written to
remove liability.
So it always sounds bad.
Terminal Service is meant to sound bad
and scary.
They're literally.
The purpose is to remove liability,
so to expect youtube.
I don't think that's a slippery slope.
If you are expecting everyone to read
the terms of service,
every partner that I've ever worked
with,
I mean on,
on,
on face value,
it's as reputable as a,
as a partner as you can.
Yeah.
We've had some offers for responses that
we declined that happens.
But someone like better help,
like past all the questions that you
would normally ask,
you know,
is they do have good reviews online when
we looked up.
Yeah,
of course.
No.
And people can promote people decide how
they want to promote different products.
I personally wasn't comfortable
promoting it in terms of me being
depressed and I wasn't personally
comfortable saying I've used the service
when I haven't,
but it seemed good and it seems like
it'd be useful and helpful.
So I promoted it as such.
Now,
um,
I think people are just a little too
quick to throw others under the bus and
be way overly cynical about this.
Okay.
Um,
I understand that it can seem in poor
taste to promote better help in a video
about being depressed,
which I didn't do for the record and I
have never done.
But from the flip side,
think about it from their perspective.
Someone like,
like buggy felt the Franco,
Bobby Burns,
I don't know,
Shane,
everyone think of it from their side
instead of being so cynical and thinking
that there is this elaborate scam to
them,
it's a win win.
It's like,
oh,
this app is going to help people.
It seems like a good service.
And my videos promoted.
It's like,
you know,
be optimistic about it and it feels like
a one one.
I mean,
that's how sponsors as young Youtube
I've always worked like content,
like sponsors.
If you have video game content,
you have a video game sponsorship on it.
If you make car content,
our tech content,
you have technology or car,
like,
like content,
like sponsors.
That's how it works.
So it's easy to see where people have
come from,
thinking that it's okay to pair those
up.
It seems like a win win.
Um,
and so I completely understand where
they're coming from.
Um,
and I think once again,
people are thinking about it backwards.
I think what has been happening is that
better help because there's been this
implication that people have
exaggerated,
being depressed to sell better help as
that is a very powerful.
It really shitty that would be very
shitty and the people that I've seen
being called out are people that I know
have had a history with mental health
issues and so I think it's kind of
ironic to like real and dog pile on
these people who already kind of fucked
up.
You know,
I think what I think you guys have it
backwards.
The people who are being overly cynical,
people who have spoken about mental
health issues are the people that are
being approached by better health.
Right?
So it's not,
doesn't start from wanting to sell
better help.
It starts from having these issues and
then better help comes in because they
see an opportunity.
I think that's how these partnerships
have a happened.
And then finally I've heard this
argument that it's unethical for you
tubers to even make money from promoting
a service about mental health.
That I heard that it's unethical to take
money for it,
that it should be done for free even.
And I.
Well,
who benefits from doing it for free?
Better help,
what you're going to do free copyrights
for better help their business.
You know,
as a capitalist society,
that's the way the world turns.
I mean saying it's illogical for a
utuber are immoral for youtube or to
collect money to promote better health.
Is,
is,
is similar to saying it,
is it a moral for a doctor or therapist
or nurse to get paid for their work
because it benefits people.
I mean this is a capitalist society.
We,
we.
This is how,
at what point,
where does the red line,
at what point does it become a moral
right?
There's therapists the charge $50 an
hour,
$200 an hour,
$500 an hour.
At what point does it become immoral for
therapists to charge $50 an hour?
$500 an hour.
So there's service not valuable.
Is that not a capital is not a
commodity.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
If they're better at it too,
they not deserve to get paid more.
So this blanket statement that it's
somehow immoral to sponsor online
therapy strikes me as an odd one and not
one that makes much sense.
Especially considering,
uh,
here in the United States,
our costs spittles are doctors.
Everything Cancer Treatment for Christ
sake is heavily monetized.
And I personally find that to be
disgraceful.
But are we saying that they shouldn't
get paid at all?
They should.
They volunteer.
I mean,
I,
it's a,
it's an argument that doesn't make much
sense to you and it falls apart in my
mind when you try to break it down.
I mean,
it's a nice,
it's a nice thought,
but it doesn't really make that much
sense.
Now,
once again,
I want to acknowledge this is somebody I
worked with one time months ago and I
never promoted them and context of being
depressed and I never said that I used
their service to treat my depression.
I'm not a doctor.
I'm not journalist.
I'm not a lawyer.
This is my opinion.
Feel free to disagree,
but I've been watching this kind of
devolve and I think that people are
being way overly cynical about this and
it's just another example of like,
I don't know,
it just feels like one of these things
that just making youtube even more
toxic,
like even more distrustful of people and
even more cynical of each other and to
people and I just don't know why and and
I,
I dunno,
it just didn't feel.
It just doesn't feel right.
This whole thing and sure some people
are being opportunistic.
Probably some,
but not always going to happen to
someone.
Now there's,
there's been a lot of controversy about
filter Franco because he was apparently
sponsor with them and do it.
I don't know anything about what filter
Franco's up to not commenting at all
about that.
And I know like he had a bank connected
somehow with Shane's better help.
Sponsorship.
He's not connected to us at all.
Ours came through an agency,
and let me say this,
by the way,
when you work with sponsors,
we work with a lot of sponsors here on
the podcast.
They come through agencies that vet
them,
the check for their credibility,
the collect payments and make sure
they're legit.
Okay.
Because obviously,
yeah,
so obviously we as business owners and
as entertainers are not going to read
the terms of service.
All of our partners.
That's insane.
Nobody has time for that.
So we trust our agency to,
to verify the legitimacy of these
companies and I don't think they failed
in this case.
I mean we think about it too.
I don't just pass the buck completely to
them.
I make a conscious decision to work with
someone or not,
but in this case I don't regret it.
I mean like,
yeah,
there's some questionable things in
terms of service,
but let me say this with the information
I had at the time I made the right
decision.
[inaudible]
and,
and that's it.
You know,
I think if you want to criticize the
company,
that's one thing and that's totally
fine,
but to come at Youtube,
Er's who have worked with them
seems overly cynical and toxic and it's
just not.
I don't know.
It's just not necessary.
And you guys,
another crutch of this argument is the
implication that people don't.
There's so many sponsors available on
youtube now.
You don't have to act depressed to get a
sponsor on youtube.
You really don't.
I mean,
I don't know.
It just makes it.
That whole thing just made me feel
really sad.
I felt really bad.
Honestly,
when I saw Felix is video and kind of
the way it was portrayed.
I'm not gonna lie,
I felt it felt really awful and I didn't
mean to do it,
but like I didn't want people to think.
I know a lot of people were getting the
wrong.
A lot of people went in and I felt bad
for all the other people he named two
because it's like these are people that
are already sensitive and dealing with
stuff and it's like.
It's like,
man,
I dunno.
Just overly cynical.
And again,
I chose not to talk about my depression.
People make decisions.
I didn't want to do that,
but that's just my opinion.
You can feel free to disagree with me
and that's fine.
Okay.
We can have dissenting opinions.
You don't have to come fucking murder my
family and shit down my throat because I
happen to have my own opinion about
this.
I think youtube has gotten way too
fucking toxic way to overly cynical and
when you start throwing good,
honest youtubers under the bus
that I think there,
I think we need to reel it back a little
bit.
You know,
there's some that's like,
I'm not saying that people shouldn't be
criticized,
but it's like,
I dunno,
just whatever just felt bad.
The whole thing felt bad.
So that's,
that's,
that's my take.
And I hope that you won't come to my
house at 3:00
AM and attempt to murder me over on his
dissenting opinion because it's not that
serious after all.
And if you.
And if you are thinking that you may
consider hopping over to [inaudible] dot
com slash eight,
three talking to the therapist.
Um,
God.
Okay.
I think I handled that.
I didn't get too upset,
right?
No,
I don't.
I'm not trying to throw shade at anyone.
I'm not trying to be controversial.
I'm not trying to stir the pot.
I'm tired of feeling like everyone is
out to get.
Everyone's looking at might feel ironic
coming from now.
Okay.
Let me acknowledge that somebody who
said who's notorious for,
you know,
making fun of people online.
Yeah.
But Hey,
that's just my opinion.
Okay.
On this topic specifically,
all right
also,
well,
whatever.
I think I put that to rest.
We've got lacroix.
You guys have all heard.
We're almost to a break,
but let me set this up and then we'll go
to a break.
Lacroix,
the Saudi pop of choice.
Crack open a fresh one.
Cheers.
Now,
a lot of you probably heard this
headline that Lacroix is being sued for
putting unnatural chemicals and it's
drink.
Yes.
Sip it appealing.
I'm a limonene.
How do you say that?
Lemo nine Lemo Nini.
Lemoni.
It's a chemical that is also inside
cockroach insecticide.
Now this is a heavily that has been
widely seen around social media crash.
People have been texting me.
Chris delea texted me.
He's like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Because we're both a little croix.
I didn't even drink water anymore.
I'm a lacroix.
Seriously?
Not a joke.
Don't drink water dude.
Fuck that peasant juice waters called as
inches.
Now this is cochrane is well,
is it?
You know when the Lacroix came out it
was a high.
It was a top shelf beverage.
I remember it was really expensive,
but now they saw what happened.
It's all on sale all the time.
It's like three bucks for 12 pack or
something.
Yeah,
Dude.
Fucking brutal man.
They're competing with water and you
believe that.
So anyway,
listen to me.
It sounded far fetched.
So I wanted to take a deep dive.
What's at stake?
Who are the players who benefits the
most from this?
And is it true that the Lich the Lacroix
controversy or Lacroix Gate?
Stay tuned after this break.
We will dive right into that here on the
podcast.
Gazebo experience.
Join me under the Gazebo.
Why don't you please Robin Hood as an
investing APP.
They'll let you buy and sell stocks,
etfs,
options,
and cryptos.
Here's the catch my dudes and this.
What's makes it Robin Hood.
No Commission.
That's right.
Zero.
Many of these trading after going to
charge you dollars portrayed Robin Hood.
Coby is robbin the hood for the hood.
You feel me?
They strive to make financial services
work for everyone and not just the
wealthy.
Dan uses this APP.
He loves it.
He swears by it.
I don't trade,
I don't know anything about trading,
but from what he says,
it's simple to use.
It has built in explanations and it's a
great place to learn how to trade.
That stuff's complicated.
I'm intimidated,
but Robin Hood seems to make it easy,
intuitive,
fun learning experience,
and again,
no commission on those trades.
Folks,
it's easy as that.
Robin Hood Platform lets you view stock
collections.
You can view most popular and sectors as
entertainment.
Social media can curated categories like
female ceos.
I'm invested in those crops.
The board I'm already invested in,
one and analyst ratings a buy hold,
sell for every stuff.
Learn by doing.
You're going to learn how to invest and
build your portfolio.
On Robin Hood,
they've got all the tools,
all the trades,
making all the moves.
It's everybody's invested in stock.
I'm,
I'm the odd man out.
I'm back here the other day with all of
our employees were here from teddy fresh
and age three,
and everybody's dabbling in stock.
I was like,
I gotta get on that.
Robin Hood is the place to do it.
Now,
here's what's awesome.
Robin Hood is giving our listeners a
furries out.
Tony Downey,
given our listeners a free stock like
apple for or sprint,
to help you build your portfolio for.
For a signups,
go to h,
three podcasts dot Robin Hood Dot Com
and get a random free stock.
That is freaking cool,
so head on over to hd,
podcast out Robin Hood and start trading
to day.
My Dude's listen with all the recent
news about online security breaches,
it's hard not to worry about where my
data goes.
Everybody's leaking my data,
my passwords,
my credit card,
my social security number.
It's everywhere,
and guess what?
I don't need it leaking anymore.
Making all my purchase or simply
accessing their email can put your
private information at risk.
Try accessing a non secured network.
Maybe you're at the airport.
Boom.
Guess who's got your credit card
information?
Fucking some random dude in India.
You want that guy having it?
No.
Okay,
now here's the deal.
That's why I decided to take back my
privacy and start using.
It's a perfectly good for as Vpn is easy
as apps that run seamlessly in the
background of my computer,
phone or tablet.
Turn on express.
We'd be in a protection only takes one
click because those vpn secure and
anonymized as your internet browser.
By encrypting your data and hiding your
public ip address,
protect herself expressed vpn.
It costs less than $7 a month.
I'll tell you what costs more than $7 a
month trying to get back your stolen
identity.
You've got duct the Lord.
You got to talk to government agencies.
Going to take a lot more time and money
that $7 a month to get your credit card
information back.
Your social security number,
fixed $7 a mother is a is a walk in the
park.
Protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
free and express with bn.com/a
tree that's exp,
our ess vpn.com/h
three for three months free with a one
year package.
Does it?
Express vpn.com/hp
to learn more and keep your credit card
has added a.
we're Indian dudes who want to steal
your credit card.
Not that only Indians would,
but that's just in my mind.
I imagined this where they are.
My opinions are not endorsed by Vpn.
Imagine your old coupon clipping,
grandpa.
You can shrink down and put it in your
computer and use as a plugin on your
browser all the time.
That's what honey is.
When you think,
Connie,
think grandpa clipping coupons all the
time for you on the Internet.
Here's what hunting does.
You install it.
It's a plugin.
When you shop online,
pretty much everywhere.
I'm talking Amazon,
I'm talking Ebay.
I'm talking Walmart,
macy's,
dominoes,
dominoes.
You can get pizza coupons.
They are scanning the web for the most
active uptodate,
best coupons available so that when
you're at checkout honeys like,
I got you dog,
or well,
your grandpa wouldn't say that.
What would your grandpa say?
Like a few study.
I got a coupon for that study.
That's what Hud.
He says,
I got a coupon for that sunny.
That's what honey says,
and they come at the last minute at
check out like the Americans arriving
World War II,
boom,
last minute coupon on the desk.
Look at this.
We once bought Jackson blankets.
I saved literally $360 from macy's.
Oh,
what?
That's what honey does.
Boom.
I got your sunny.
That's where your grandpa says as these
coupon clipping coupons all night by the
fireplace.
That's what honey does for you.
I'm telling you,
try it out.
It's free.
It's risk free.
It's just a chrome extension.
It takes just two clicks to install.
Give it a shot for a week and see if you
don't love it.
Apparently.
What did they say that it saved are
saved?
Are Our audience hundreds of thousands
of dollars who have already used this
like it's got five stars,
100,005
star reviews and 10 million members.
Are you freaking kidding me?
Never overpay again with honey.
So let them know who sent you go to get
a goto join honey.com/h
three.
That's joint on e dot gob slash h three.
Welcome back.
My little gazebos.
Um,
before we get into,
is Lacroix poison?
I want to say new age three video out,
which was a lot of fun.
Honestly.
I got to say I really want this one.
I took my time,
I enjoyed the process.
I took all the time I needed on.
We worked on it for like two weeks and I
would just sit down and edit and enjoy
the experience and the sketch and
everything.
So I think that I really enjoyed and the
reception was amazing.
I mean everyone was really happy about
it.
I got to say I didn't think.
I don't think I saw one complaints
actually have a collection of them for
you.
If you want me to read those off real
quick,
you know,
I'm just going to do it.
There's no complaints guys.
Why don't we sit over in the Gazebo and
it felt good.
I think me and Isla realized,
I think recently we felt Ngozi boys
because the boys.
I like that.
That feels special.
Are you a busy boy?
Z Boys?
Maybe we should name our child
[inaudible],
but that's a good like gender neutral
name because just given birth under a
gazebo.
You know,
how people have all these weird like
given water waterpool a gazebo.
Birth a blessing because it's a
beautiful thing.
I feel like,
um,
I've seen some people echoing the
sentiment that I,
I have spoken a lot of times that I
don't want to be making videos like
that,
but I feel like recently I have always
wanted to go back to making videos like
that and just until recently we weren't
meant.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's what I mean,
that's what it was really.
It was just that I,
I,
I literally couldn't.
I don't know what it was,
but recently we really felt like we
wanted to try and go back to making like
high quality.
I feel like they can embrace for like we
didn't make a video.
It's like three months and kind of
started to crave the feeling of like
being creative and doing something.
Yeah,
that's what it was born from that we
really wanted to say,
okay,
let's make the best video.
We can not cut any corners.
There's no deadline.
And so that's what we did.
And it was fun.
It was great.
I loved everything.
So hopefully more to come.
Um,
so anyway,
I'm glad you guys enjoyed and thanks for
all the wonderful comments and support
tomorrow and Los Angeles for all of our
La based [inaudible] boys.
Um,
where,
what,
what time is it at now?
You're surprising me with you can just
google rip into right store.
But what time is it at?
11.
Hold on.
All right,
well either.
Does that check out?
This new teddy fresh?
What do you call this track suit?
Warmer.
It's a tracksuit tracksuit that's coming
out this winter.
They get this fresh shit.
The fit is insane.
The comfort level.
This shit is spicy hot.
It's breathe,
dude.
This thing is insane.
This is so comfortable.
I mean it was my goal for a long time to
Mecca tracks.
Ketty fresh watch out.
Watch out haters.
Because Teddy fresh is calming hard.
So it's at 11:00
AM tomorrow,
Tomorrow at 11:00
AM at [inaudible] store.
It's next to the supreme store.
And is it Hollywood and La Fairfax
Avenue effect.
So we'll be there for about an hour or
two and got the new rip indep
collection.
Co Lab coming out.
Very excited about.
So.
So he goes there and um,
let's do it.
Is Lacroix poison?
That is the question we are looking to
resolve today.
Who are the players at work?
Who benefits from this?
Before we get into this lacroix boy,
uh,
under the Gazebo.
A story I'd like to say cheers to
everybody in the boys and back to enjoy
everyone.
Crack Open Your Lacroix and have a nice
refreshing sip of all natural essence
sodie pop.
That's good.
So a new lawsuit alleges that a lacroix
is not all natural and the chemical
limonene in Lacroix is also an cockroach
insecticide.
Now,
one thing that I thought,
first of all when I heard that is just
because it's toxic to cockroaches,
doesn't necessarily mean anything.
You hear shit like that all the time.
Like our neighbors,
the vet,
he says,
chewing gum,
artificial sweetening,
chewing gum is deadly poisonous to dogs.
Just because it's toxic to cockroach
doesn't like.
That.
Seems like an effort to scare.
Like if it's dangerous to humans,
say that it's dangerous to cockroaches.
Cockroaches are gross and I have a
mental image of dead cockroaches,
but it doesn't necessarily mean anything
besides that.
So that seems kind of manipulative
headline.
So at first something,
what's going on here?
You know,
is this really about the ingredients or
something else at play?
So let's actually break down these
claims from the lawsuit who were making
these claims.
All right,
let's start with the chemical Lemo Nini.
Am I saying that right?
Or am I just sound like an idiot?
A feeling?
You're not saying,
how could I?
It cannot be called limonene.
And then somebody for Christ sake help
me.
I'll check gleam on any line.
One nine.
Oh Lima nine.
That's gotta be it.
That sounds way more intelligent in
America.
And I'm so bad at pronounciating things.
It's like ridiculous.
Alignment nine,
I think it's Lima nine.
Damn.
You killed it.
You just read it like someone from
outside of the US,
would it?
Well,
I'm sorry.
My brain is fucked up.
So pub cam,
the National Institutes of health open
database for chemical compounds
explicitly calls Lima Nine,
a naturally occurring chemical and a
major component of oil extraction from
citrus peels.
So sounds pretty natural,
right?
As the name suggests,
limonene is commonly used to give food
or other products a lemony flavor and
fragrance.
So it is a naturally occurring compound
that comes off of lemons.
So Lima,
Lima Damn crushed it.
You're fucking spelling bee champ.
So how about the claims that it causes
kidney toxicity and cancer while the
same company pub cam also states there
is inadequate evidence in humans for the
carcinogenic properties have limonene.
There is some evidence of male rats
experiencing problems including tumors
as a consequence of limonene exposure.
But none of those findings have been
properly reproduced in humans.
Meanwhile,
more recent study suggests that limonene
is actually anti cancer.
It's lemon.
I mean it's a naturally occurring lemon.
Now,
how did this company come to claim that
it's even unnatural?
Because I was reading that the FDA,
because everything that FDA does is so
nebulous and undefined,
defines for whatever reason,
lemo nene as artificial flavor.
But according to this magazine,
and I don't know what the reason is for
that.
Is it a naturally occurring chemical
that comes from lemon?
Okay.
Now the other chemical that's being
accused of being toxic is Lena Lou.
I.
Why?
Why can I not really?
You know,
Lou,
it's spelled L I n a l o l that's a
goofy ass word.
Lena Lou as another additive used as a
flavoring agent.
It's naturally occurring.
Found within many types of flowers.
Spice plants,
including the nights.
Yeah.
It includes meant centered herbs,
laurels,
and cinnamon.
It is most definitely used an
insecticide as well.
That part is true,
but that doesn't mean it's poisonous to
humans.
After all,
as I pointed out,
dogs can eat chocolate,
get I eat 20 bars a day.
Explain that you can't.
The only real toxic effects of Lena Lou
has been documented to inflict on humans
is mild skin and eye irritation,
namely from air assault,
from air forms of the chemical being
supported in your eyes.
For example,
take 11.
Squirt it in your eyes.
Oh,
I'm going to sue the lemon people.
No,
that's not how it works.
Folks.
Also,
coincidentally,
research suggests that it may be an
anticancer ingredient that leaves only
lionel prop property such as Lionel
property and a proper proper property
and a like back in fifth grade trying to
read again,
read to the class even.
Can you read a paragraph in front of the
class?
And it's like,
oh my God,
I can't remember half these words.
That leaves Lionel prep innate derived
from plants like ginger and lavender and
another common flavoring and fragrance
additive.
It has been shown to help inhibit the
proliferation of prostate cancer.
I'm going to show those.
Wrap up my ass at least in the form of
Nagani Kumquats.
Um,
uh,
so there you go.
So unless Lacroix is secretly including
50 percent of the beverage as Lionel,
then drinkers don't have anything to
fear because it's not even anywhere
close to being harmful.
These are all naturally occurring
flavors.
And by the way,
these are all flavors that many
companies use and many of their products
to flavor their beverages.
I mean it makes it act like Lacroix is
out there.
Just a pouring coke,
gross insecticide for no reason.
Like I'm going to save fifty cents and
pour some pointed at as.
No.
This is a widely used flavoring agent
that seems by all accounts to be natural
after all.
So what's going on here?
What is going on?
Let me say this.
Even water is toxic.
When you consume too much,
you can actually get water poisoning.
Okay?
No,
that's an incredible sued a water.
I'm assuming big water.
Now,
as somebody who's been on the receiving
end of bogus lawsuits,
this place,
this lawsuit stinks to high.
Heck,
okay.
Now Mike Theory,
big soda is behind it and I.
That might sound like a joke,
but think about it.
The company Lacroix dominates,
dominates the market.
If you go to any grocery store,
any convenience store gets what's on the
shelf and guess what?
People want Lacroix every time.
Isla,
please.
Let's not get into that.
Now.
That's a whole nother heated debate.
Look,
they got a great marketing.
I don't know what.
I don't know how,
but they dominant like I've.
I've slammed Lacroix previously on the
podcast was like these motherfuckers act
like they invented soda water,
but here I am drinking it every episode.
So what's going on now at the same time
as Lacroix is killing it and I'm talking
about $827,000,000
in sales last year.
Guess what's simultaneously declining
hugely and sales soda,
sugary drinks as people realize that
consuming 50 grams of sugar is poison
and not lie on the oil or whatever.
How about 50 grams of sugar?
Can we sue Coca Cola for giving me
diabetes?
I'd like to.
Maybe I will.
So here we have lacroix dominating the
market.
Big Soda falling down.
What's happening now?
The these big boys are losing market
share to Lacroix and their soda water
brands are are getting smashed,
they're dominating the market.
And these big soda companies,
they they need to get in because their
business is suffering.
So to me from the outside,
it seems like a total hit job of
misinformation and the lawsuit is going
to get thrown out.
You can trust me on that,
but the damage has already been done
because I hear it on the news,
I see it on social media,
I see it everywhere at once.
And it stuck in your head.
I know.
And a know fucked up is that nobody
goes,
nobody goes,
oh,
that's weird.
That doesn't make that much sense.
They say they go,
what?
There's poison in Lacroix.
We're all fucking going to die.
We drink lacroix.
And they have successfully
tarnish the reputation of this pristine,
beautifully branded and naturally
flavored sodie pop.
And that's it.
That's the beauty of this lawsuit.
It's totally bogus.
It's going to get thrown out and they
have tarnished the reputation and
everybody's been taken the bait.
And meanwhile Mr Coca Cola has got his
feet up and he's drinking lacroix.
He knows it's the security of beverage.
But meanwhile he's pedaling his fucking
nasty coca cola bullshit.
So I say to all of our listeners,
all the [inaudible] boys out there,
crack open a lacroix,
have a sip and enjoy yourself and know
that you are enjoying an all natural
sugar free beverage.
And you are,
you are a lacroix boy.
Your Gazebo.
Boy,
you are my boy.
So have a sip and enjoy.
Cheers everybody.
Cheers.
Isla,
you really?
That's allowed 70 though.
I tried on purpose.
So that's it.
Nice to have bunked two big topics.
Sixty minutes is this 60 minutes
colgate.
I was working on my Alex Jones
impression.
I thought it was pretty good.
I did it during one of the,
the uh,
copywriters,
but we cut it,
but I kind of want to do it now.
Kanye.
Kanye gave trump,
make America great hat during his White
House visit.
And it really hurts my throat though.
It's pretty good.
I need to figure how to do it where it
doesn't irritate my throat.
Yeah.
Kanye gave trump will make America great
hat during the White House visit.
Purple Hat.
You guys heard about all this?
Kanye west madness.
Um,
okay.
So let's talk about Kanye West.
No good.
That Kanye met trump and we're going to
talk about that,
but before we do in our intern,
who's a super fan of Kanye West says you
will know,
um,
had some suggestions for Kanye West last
week and our previous episode,
he had suggested that he make the hat
purple,
which would symbolize the joining of the
Democrats and the Republicans.
They're red and the blue.
Exactly.
Red And blue makes purple cares.
Here's Kanye and a purple hat.
Not Evidence of much.
Honestly,
we had thought that it said make America
great.
You can't really read it,
can you?
It doesn't say that though,
but interesting.
What does it say?
Showing up.
Inappropriate hat says exposed world
says Ian because he knows those world,
but what he did,
and then his other suggestion in
suggestion was don't wear a hat that
says make America great again.
Hat that says make America great.
Yeah.
And what happens later on that day,
my friends.
Well,
I can't open it some behind that
picture.
It is,
yeah.
Good job.
He'll make America great.
This is,
I'm telling it now.
People have suspected that Kanye lurks
the reddit of Kanye on Reddit and the
clip,
the highlight of and talking about it
was that subreddit.
So there is a chance,
I swear to you now that Kanye West saw
Ian suggestion and if he comes out with
a purple,
make America great hat,
which is a great idea and I hope he does
the world.
Oh my God.
That is going to be amazing.
How well.
Well,
how,
how do you,
how did you feel in seeing this?
I saw you.
You seem pretty excited.
Yeah,
I mean I was pretty proud of myself.
Do you think that he saw your
presentation?
I'm going to tell myself that.
Yeah,
I hope you did.
Do you think there's a chance though,
or do you think.
I mean like not going to fully commit
because it's not purple.
If it was purple,
I'd go he,
yeah,
but well,
based on a percentage out of 100,
what are the chances do you think you
saw that your presentation,
the clip got a lot of views.
That was six days ago before he did
that.
It's interesting timing and this looks
like a shitty one.
Not like the design one.
He pooped it out real fast.
Yeah.
You could just buy a red hat and the
embroidery.
Can you give me a percentage?
Say 50.
Wow.
That's gotTa.
Make you feel amazing.
Oh yeah.
He better send me a hat.
That's the least he could do.
Look us up.
Wow.
I hope he takes.
Would you wear it in if it was purple
and said make America Great.
What if it was a one?
If it's red,
he's like,
no,
I don't kind eat on the street.
I wouldn't wear it if it was red.
No,
if it was purple,
I feel like I kind of have to know what
the fuck you can't.
Yeah.
I love that.
You wouldn't wear.
You wouldn't wear it.
Well.
Anyway,
so there's that and so we all
congratulate in.
He's really grown up.
We're all very proud of him.
What the fuck going on?
We're all very proud of an intern.
He's really flourished.
He's turned into condos.
Personal advisor really just come into
his own,
so I want to say thank you to end the
intern.
He's great,
and when we first saw that purple hat,
there was that moment where we thought
that was it.
That was a freak out.
That was like,
are you kidding me?
But 50 percent though,
Dan.
I mean that's nothing to be scoffed.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I think he's probably right.
I mean from what I understand,
yeah,
he,
he legitimately is like,
he's a worker.
He's on the Kanye Fan.
For how many points did it have on the
rabbit in?
Well,
it wasn't on the,
reddit was on the fence.
Oh Man.
Forum.
And how was it received?
A people were onboard connecting
everyone to shit on me and yeah,
that would be interesting.
Well maybe not him personally,
but you know,
I bet some of his handlers probably do
check out,
you know,
let's just go,
go,
let's go with that.
Wow.
That's,
that's really exciting.
Well,
did you out your user name then if you
posted our wellness?
Someone else posted it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's still clear your alerts on the
them,
you didn't post it.
Did you end up denying it?
Fuck,
it was definitely y'all know his
account.
Um,
but anyway,
so Kanye met with trump and there's a
lot of blow back as you can expect,
but I'm here to focus on the funny,
the whimsical,
the comedic.
Um,
so here's,
here's
one great moment.
Um,
you can see Kanye password on his phone
came in.
I was like,
Ian,
what's funniest password?
And he's like just zeros as I come in
and he's like five,
like you're fucking crazy to six 67.
Six.
Okay.
Yeah,
you said 5:10,
but I guess he's revised his.
He said he went back into and this whole
thing,
ellen on one of his legendary I airplane
the airplane.
We have a picture that but trump card.
Interesting cognition.
Just going off for like 20 minutes and
dominating the conversation and I find
it just so interesting that,
oh,
how do I get that Angle Bac this angle
here?
He doesn't really look at trump when
he's talking and trumps faith.
Is he just sitting there kind of
embracing this angle is all is in the
one I wanted for Christ sake.
What else?
We got up?
Kanye is a smart as tesla and Freud.
See if ben can decode this.
I was conducted with a neuropsychologist
that works,
Matt,
but the athletes in the NBA,
the NFL,
and he looked at my brain,
go ahead,
drop some bombs for you.
Ninety eight percent top out you test.
I had a 75 percentile of all human
beings,
but it was counting eight numbers
backwards afterwards.
Repeat something going to work on that
one.
The other one's 98 percent tesla.
Freud,
you know,
so
I guess he's trying to say he's very
intelligent.
Am I correct in that?
And he's definitely coming across that
way.
And you're not commenting really.
I think he's pursuing his words,
but uh,
he's got the whole forum listening on
everyday.
Things got so complicated for men.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you can't just take tuck his
opinion anymore.
He's a leader.
He's a thought leader on it by his PR
and influencer.
I know what you need to pr now.
Can't have the.
He's got a reputation now.
He doesn't have some bullshit username
he's faced.
They know who he is.
He has a reputation.
If he says the wrong thing,
this called Bob's coming from.
Yeah.
This goes beyond username.
This is real shit.
Well,
Ian,
can you at least confirm he's,
he's trying to say that he is
intelligent.
Yeah,
that's the general idea.
Yeah.
I mean it's once again,
like the powerpoint where I showed all
the people you can compare themselves,
surprises,
Freud and a tesla.
Wasn't the in there.
And who was the,
uh,
the Disney character.
Oh,
that's vanilla pea von sweets,
sweets.
He should have said,
I'm like sweet.
Then as counting eight numbers.
Gosh,
we're gonna work on it.
And we were working on not doing the
math anyway,
the other one's 98 percent tests.
Look Freud,
you know,
so he knows,
say confidence,
you know what I'm saying?
But anyway,
so that was the number one rock star on
the planet.
So that was interesting.
And then there was the one,
I guess the one that really pissed
people off was that he hugged trump at
the end and we saw this doctor or this
and this isn't God.
He showed him a picture of what does
this even in hell.
Yeah.
And decode.
It's not his design.
He took it from someone who did it as
they're a university thesis a few years
ago,
and the guy,
they asked him,
they were like,
what do you think about this?
He's like,
I think it's got a cool that Connie saw
it.
He didn't care that I have no idea how.
So what are the chances we're going to
get this air force one made in zero
percent.
Okay.
Alright.
Hater form's gonna eat you alive for
that one.
So bring back that picture.
You love them all wearing hats.
Yeah.
Connie,
I gave.
Um,
I wanna see I wanna.
See Jared Kushner.
He looks like such a Dweeb.
Um,
you can see the whole family here and
one says,
make earth the greatest again.
Make earth great again.
Earth is like,
don't talk for me.
It says,
yeah,
I know jared cracks make earth grade
again.
And travel space again.
Make Earth grade again.
What does that mean?
One was earth.
Earth used to be fucking dope when the
dinosaurs were around,
maybe played out,
played out,
and it would carry.
It looked so uncomfortable in that hat,
man.
But they're,
they're making them work,
they're rocking it,
they're making it work.
What's the Blue Ones Day?
That's the earth.
That's the black line.
Says travel space again.
So you can,
you can get that out,
get that out of there.
So then we've got the hug,
the notorious hug,
which apparently now I was like in what?
Because they're,
the backlash has been so severe and I've
read some things like Tei,
the famous rapper,
what he wrote.
I was like,
damn,
that is fucking harsh.
And their friends on my read it for you
guys.
But I was like,
Ian,
what?
What exactly did he say that that upset
people so much.
And what in?
Well,
in you want to say what you told me?
Or is that too controversial?
I don't remember that.
He didn't say anything new.
It was kind of the same antics.
It's the same content from the last six
months.
But I guess what happened is he showed a
lot of love and he hugged trump and
that's what set people off.
So extend them together and made it all
medium.
So here it is.
Well that I like and I guess they liked
me and we're going to have lunch.
We're gonna talk.
You don't want to take.
I don't want to put you in that spot,
but standing in that spot.
I love this guy right here.
I did the secret service.
Not tackled his ass right now.
I love this.
Got You.
It was all a long call and there was
like a plot to a movie like that where
he tries to get close to the king.
Some Kung Fu movie hero.
Yeah.
That movie's sick.
What did it make sense of?
Konya was like the star of his own hero
and he just stabbed trump.
That'd be a wild twit.
Everyone's like,
whoa,
no,
but he didn't.
He didn't stab him
and it gave him some love and in fact
that probably ruined the moment for you
guys.
So let me go back.
I have a bad habit of pausing and
talking a lot and isla was trying to
correct me,
but it was too late.
I already paused it.
So here we go again for everyone to
enjoy.
Well,
people that I like and I guess they
liked me and we're going to have lunch.
We're going to talk.
I don't want to take.
I don't want to put you in that spot,
dude.
I'm sorry.
I got to get all these people.
There's so many people from so many
press.
It's actually really annoying.
You can't even hear what they're saying.
Cameras that can take pictures.
Do you need.
What the fuck does she know about
cameras?
Taylor?
I'm.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not going to pause it anymore.
That's fine.
I love this guy right here.
Let me get this.
Really
hard.
I didn't want to put you in that
present.
There you go.
Okay,
now let me read the response to the
flavor.
The reaction.
This,
uh,
this was cold blooded man.
This,
this,
you know what happened?
He got
go.
Sarah did.
I was trying to.
He got ghost started by a t I.
and do you agree this was a ghost
starting?
Yeah,
it was a good start.
Definitely goes right.
So let me read this shit now.
I've been extremely patient and made it
a point to not jump to any premature
conclusions about you and his antics,
partially due to the lessons learned
from the outcome of other similar
situation dealing with my brother Wayne,
which I mailed him mishandled a bit in
hindsight,
but now this shit is next level
futuristic sambo hopping Bob Steven off.
Django ass shit.
What does that mean in
those are all references to.
It's sort of like the,
the uncle Tom thing.
What a sambo.
Uh,
that was,
uh,
it was a book that had like very racist
imagery,
I believe.
I'm not exactly sure,
but then he refers to Django,
which obviously that was the term Tina
movie.
Sure.
Okay.
Literary references very,
uh,
eyebrow.
You know,
from what I can gather,
this is the most repulsive,
disgraceful,
embarrassing act of desperation and
auction off of one solid again,
power I've ever seen.
Now I recall you asking me to come with
you to have this meeting and I declined
naturally,
but bro,
if ain't time,
I would've been in there with you and
you behave that spinelessly in my
presence.
I feel I'd be compelled to slap the fuck
out of you,
Bro,
for the people you asked,
kissing and boot licking on a whole new
level,
and I refused to associate myself with
something so vile week and inconsiderate
to the effect this has on the greater
good of all of our people.
I'm a true believer in it ain't what you
do,
it's how you do it and this shit is
regurgitating at one time.
It was a pleasure to work alongside you.
Now I'm ashamed to have been associated
with you.
To all the people who follow.
You.
Use the Yay.
Oh fuck.
Yay.
Right?
Yes.
Kanye was not part of a former.
Anything of people.
Don't judge,
so other people will follow.
Yay.
Musically,
socially,
or even personally who are confused,
heartbroken and fear.
Eat.
Let me make this clear.
This shit ain't cool.
This is all in caps.
This is a movie made.
Yay.
Yes.
Made for Yay.
This is a play to put him in position.
He'd liked to see himself in.
We are not on his mind as he makes these
comments in decisions.
Don't follow this puppet where we're off
caps now because as long as I've lived,
I've learned that it benefits a man.
Nothing at all to gain the world if to
do so,
he must lose his soul.
We just saw Mr.
West soul on auction.
If you listen closely,
can hear the tears of our ancestors hit
the floor.
All I can say is I've reached my limit.
This is my stop.
I'm officially done.
Middle Finger trump and his little cooky
boy.
Wow.
That's cold blooded shit.
How did,
how did you,
how did that make you feel in.
I mean,
I,
I can't fully weigh in on what that
imagery feels like or to see that if
you're,
you know,
uh,
African American in this country.
I don't know.
So yeah,
I,
I completely understand it.
I see why he would have that.
And you know,
I respect his opinion.
They're very political.
One t I did from what I understand was
like his most ardent defender up to this
point,
is that true in opinion is working on
campaigning now.
It's a tough situation for them.
I can only imagine that's got it as if
I'm calling you for.
Yeah,
that's good.
When I read it and it's hard to disagree
when this stuff that saying so I don't
know.
Like we said last time,
like you can see what kind of was trying
to do,
but in it's not a pure art movement.
It's bullet,
political and then it should be.
I guess it's,
it's just so polarizing.
It's like on one hand I see where he's
coming from and on the other hand I see
the black community as seeing Donald
Trump as a symbol of oppression of
establishment or whatever.
Yeah.
No,
but I also see like,
I dunno,
I see it from both sides.
I can't really think he's going to try
and run for president to.
I don't think so.
Fucking cringey Bro.
Please.
No,
not support.
And do you vote for Kanye would never
vote for it because I liked it.
Doesn't that kind of run everything?
What is.
So if he's read love is president or is
it just as he.
Is he just trying to get political?
What is this?
Is he trying to be genuine and spread
love and like bridge the divide or.
So you just want to run for president
positioning himself because that's what
Tai was saying and I was like,
yeah.
And the conversation was very like about
Kanye,
like it was talking about yeezy and
Adidas and how now.
So strange lands are a billion.
Oh yeah,
no.
Yeah.
And it's Kinda like,
what is the conversation with Kanye?
Watching his rent strikes me very much
as somebody who is having a manic
episode,
he's been diagnosed as bipolar and when
I see him talking there,
he strikes me as someone that's not
fully grounded,
you know what I'm saying?
And so I take that into consideration
too.
Yeah.
And Mike,
he's feeling strong more than usual
emotions because he's in this manic
state.
And so he's like,
I love trump.
I love what he represents as someone who
did something that was impossible,
I love what the idea of what he's trying
to do of like bringing jobs back to
America and America first.
Right?
Kanye sees that as he just sees the best
in it.
He sees the positive message and he
doesn't and there's a lot of people that
criticize that movement,
but he just,
he's full with strong emotions in love
and this manic state and so that's,
he's not,
he's not being smart.
He's being emotional and so it's like A.
Y'all really says that it was it in the
snl speech.
He straight up says like,
we need to start thinking with our minds
and start thinking with our hearts.
So I think he's just,
he's not an A.
I don't think he's grounded right home
and apparently or well we are noticing
earlier he talks about how he was
misdiagnosed as bipolar and he was just
sleep deprived and so he's off his
medicine and I'm watching this and be
like,
dude,
you must be really sleep deprived right
now if that's the case.
So I don't know.
The whole thing is just wild and weird.
Is he going to run as a republican
because that's kind of what he's angling
for.
Independent.
He might just try and do his own thing.
What a circus.
That would be a real circus.
Maybe he wants vp trump.
Kanye.
Won't that be a wild world?
God.
So that is Kanye decoded here on 60
minutes.
Rockstar heavy shit.
Um,
there you go.
Welcome.
Hit me with that 60 minutes tonight
under the Gazebo.
Lacroix.
Is it poisonous?
I say Fuck No.
Get that shit on sale.
Little Cooky boy,
Aka Kanye West.
That doesn't sound good.
Oh,
I can't say that.
Is that racist?
No.
Wait little cookie by racist.
He did throw that in while listing off
like Samba and all those other things.
I,
I've never heard of that one either.
I didn't know that was a racist thing is
that he just ran into him.
He said he was a smart cookie.
I was exonerated.
So hit me with that.
Sixty minutes is Kanye west trump's
little cooky boy.
Find out today under the Gazebo and
better help.
Is it a scam?
Some say yes.
Some say no.
Cockroaches.
I like that.
A Nazi or whatever.
Yeah.
I love the noncommittal.
Always hear it down here.
The craziest clickbait on the news.
They go see there's an outbreak of the
flu.
Should you be concerned?
Find out like universally when they say
that it just,
it means it means no.
No,
you shouldn't.
Imagine if the answer's yes.
Yes.
You should not leave your house a bolas
back.
The black plague is rampant.
Yes,
we.
What else we got,
man.
Everyone having fun on this Friday.
[inaudible].
Find out more tonight.
Is Kanye trump's little cooky boy?
Yes.
The answer is we should watch this pro
life lady.
Oh,
you want to watch that?
Yeah,
we've got a lot of stuff.
But ilos got suggestion,
so let's watch it.
You guys may have seen this great little
one pro life lady,
man,
roundhouse kicks pro life woman.
This shit's crazy,
man.
I love this.
This is why we're here.
My dudes.
5 million.
Wow.
This went viral.
Look at his outfit.
First of all,
he's got boots for kicking and that's
just what he'll do.
No spoilers.
Imagine kicking somebody.
Just imagine kicking somebody like how
fucking unstable that you have to be to
throw a kick.
I have I ever kicked anyone who can.
Like,
if you're not enough UFC fighting rings.
There's no like throwing a kick.
Like,
who are you?
Bruce?
Lee,
what?
Hey,
destruction of private property,
you get raped by somebody and they're
like,
hi,
I'm a 16 year old and I can have this
really compelling.
I am pro choice by the way,
for I'm.
I'm strongly in favor of pro choice.
I'm just going to say that for the
record.
Okay,
and if you think that makes me a cook or
whatever,
that's fine because we can have a
difference in opinion.
I respect that you are pro life.
How about that?
You fucking haters.
You can have an opinion and I can have a
different opinion.
Do you want to come to my dressing?
Kill me because I'm pro choice.
Suck my tiny Jewish Dick.
But this guy's a fucking idiot.
So it's fun to watch.
It's a baby.
Get someone who was raped and she gave
birth and she decided to kill her
by the way.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
No,
I did the perfect.
I just wanted to say like people who are
pro life,
I understand their point because it
comes from a religious place and they
think you're murdering a baby.
I personally disagree.
I don't think you're murdering a baby,
but if you did think that,
then I can understand how you get and
why would you be so passionate about it.
So it's like it's just slick.
Unsolvable.
Yeah,
it's killing babies.
Killing babies.
It's like,
I can't think of two more opposites.
Killing a baby.
Worse thing ever.
Not killing a baby,
you know?
I don't think it's killing baby.
This guy certainly doesn't.
You got to go back a little because I
think this guy should have been aborted.
Oof,
oof
child.
I met the kick your phone.
Okay,
well who does that imagine kicking
someone's phone?
It's still assault defendant.
He doesn't really apologize either.
He's just like,
I fucked up.
I kicked you in the face or phone.
Look at that tongue out.
It's like an animated movie.
I can probably run with his arms back.
I didn't kill her three year old child.
He rounds up,
baby.
Take your swaying hip into it.
Here we go.
That's basically a warning shot.
You know,
you heard in world war two and World War
Two and Israel does it over like Gaza.
They'll drop leaflets and say,
Hey,
we're about to bomb this place.
Get better.
Get Out.
That's what he's doing.
Dropping leaflets on,
hey,
it's about to go down.
Can you say that you clear the area
because a bomb is about to drop.
Oh,
wow.
That's a crazy kick.
I doubt that guy will,
as much power to be frank.
Can we slow motion?
Not here.
Let's,
let's go to point two five on this.
Break it down.
Um,
speed point two,
five.
Let's enjoy.
Okay,
go ahead.
Oh,
that sounds cool.
Let's make it about it.
I love how the conversation is over and
very powerful.
I'm like,
he probably doesn't have a lot of muscle
mass,
but he runs a well formed kick right
there.
Sounds a towel.
There you go.
Everyone enjoyed that one.
That was a favorite of the week.
Uh,
Shane continues his documentary about
Jake Paul.
I don't have that much to say about any
of his new series except for this.
This was my favorite detail that came
out of the new episode.
It's a small little detail,
but I thought it was great.
I'll share it for you guys.
Now what?
What's the school bus?
So my dad's
a good old Greg Paul.
It's actually like an rv though.
I'm going to give you a quick tour and
the bus give you an update.
It's like you can like renovate.
Yeah,
there's like a.
there's like a bed in there and he
drives around and like he sleeps in
there.
My Dad,
his dad has lived at the 10th one house
per months,
sleeping and a school van outside the
house.
Now a guy who's been accused of having
sex with underage girls and kissing
underage girls on camera should not be
sleeping in a school bus outside a house
with a bunch of young kids.
All right,
Greg Ball.
Get your fucking shit together.
Get your life together and get the
fucking move out of the school bus for
Christ's sake.
Greg.
What the Hell is wrong with you
as a Weirdo?
I love that.
Yeah.
Weirdest.
God Damn Shit.
I read Paul,
man.
Walk me your life together,
God,
that's it.
That's my uh,
that's my takeaway.
Banksy.
Shreds is art and whatever some
bullshit.
Should I talk about this?
See Shreds his art.
It's kind of cool except it was kind of
also lane if I'm being honest because.
Well here let's watch video.
So banksy sold a piece of art or.
No,
he didn't sell.
I don't know how came to be in the front
of his art.
So he sold it originally and then it was
recently.
I don't know.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I believe in being auctioned.
I think the story goes that he built the
shredder into it.
I'm like 10 years ago with the intention
that it,
if it ever went on auction he would do
this.
So this is like a long con,
but what I'm wondering is if he is so
anti capitalist,
he originally sold the art to somebody.
Right?
Like how did the auction house get it?
That's a very good question.
I mean the guy is rich.
Very rich.
Okay.
So I don't really understand.
So it's not really a.
is it a statement?
I'm not sure.
What was the statement?
Just to gag.
Gotcha.
Okay.
It's like,
just like an actual quilt prank.
I thought he was like an anticapitalist
didn't sell his work kind of thing.
Someone explicitly,
he doesn't sell his work,
like I remember hearing a story about
how someone had a bunch of his work on
display and they were charging him to
get in and he was super unhappy about
that because you can buy prints over the
art and I'm sure Monday won't go so
well.
I don't know much about him so nobody
knows.
Right.
That's some.
That's what I think.
Just I just had to blast you with those.
All right,
so here we go.
In a thread into the brain
and there you have it.
Years later sold for one point $4,
million dollar they're adopting and,
and the minute it closes somebody with a
real mode activated it.
Who was there not that a big ass smile
on it.
It's a shame.
It didn't complete it because they were
able to preserve it.
So that's why I think like it's done
so beautifully to the,
like the paper didn't get crumbled or
anything.
It's just like.
So is it?
So again that's my question is about his
intention because I don't think his
intention was to destroy it
because it only shreds half.
And then it stopped.
I think it's a statement because she
just,
someone just paid one point 4 million
for this up since he did it.
So now,
not only is it a valuable piece of
history,
I know it's part of his theory of art.
I mean it's pretty cool that he pulled
that off.
I'm just confused about the message
because it increased the value and it
seemed like he intentionally didn't
destroy the whole painting.
I don't care that much and I don't think
it matters that much.
I think it was still a cool moment.
People were freaking out,
like all of a sudden this paper
shredding itself.
Right?
Well,
it's possible.
It was an intentional that it fucked up.
Like if he really built this thing 10
years ago,
like malfunction,
I'm sharing you that this would raise
the volume just because that's how art
goes that moment.
That never happened before.
So yeah.
I mean it's brilliant.
It's brilliant that long.
You waited patiently for 10 years for
this beautiful model where some idiot,
I don't want to call them an idiot.
I'll put it this way.
Kurt Vonnegut,
I love this saying,
and I'm not talking,
you can spend 10,
20,
$30,000
on a piece of art and culture,
but when you start spending like
millions,
you're paying for prestige,
right?
Yeah.
Kurt vonnegut has this great quote.
He says,
art is a conspiracy between the rich and
and like the,
uh,
end the art world to make.
I said,
that's so bad to make people feel
stupid.
Or is it a conspiracy between rich
people and artist to make poor people
feel stupid because you see a painting
sold for 20 million bucks and you're
making $30,000
a year and you're like,
what the fuck?
Now the funny stories that some other
guy who owns a print shredded it carries
more weight,
is do we have a picture of that?
Oh,
that's funny.
We have A.
I want to see that is hilarious.
Was that a valuable print before of
$40,000?
So why the fuck?
Like what did he take a scissor to it?
I'm not sure.
Oh,
here it is.
So I,
I personally think that that was
intentional.
How it stopped right there.
It's kind of still beautiful.
It is very beautiful.
So what it was is,
I mean,
he wasn't destroying someone's
purchased.
He was a,
it was a little bit of a gift.
Everyone freaked out.
Definitely ended up as a gift.
I mean,
the guy who bought it had the option to
back out and he was like,
fuck,
no,
I want that.
Yeah.
It's kind of like by you.
You remember Mark Mcgrath?
What was that guy's name?
The baseball player that like broke the
home run record and mark mcgwire Mark
Mcguire,
market country sugar sugar.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
Sugar,
a sugar ray.
He,
he broke the home run record and uh,
the foul ball hit into the stadium.
The guy who caught it,
Isla sold it for 3 million bucks and
then extends.
Everyone was on steroids.
They kept breaking the record like every
year.
So it lost all of its value.
But this is that foul ball.
So a closed down one.
Oh,
and that.
Okay.
So here,
here,
read that
today.
My art broker.com
received this seller and Korea via
website from someone who has taken it
upon themselves to shred their own grill
with blueprint in order to increase its
value.
They have taken a piece of art,
earthly rough worth the 40,000
pounds and in our opinion,
made its value one.
Come on.
That's so stupid.
Why would you?
Uh,
I don't think there's pictures of it.
They,
I don't think they even want to give
that guy any attention.
That's crazy to actually take a genuine
piece of art,
valuable art and just be like,
oh,
I'm going to fucking cut it up now.
Like that's not how it works.
The seller wanted them to list it as a
80,
80,000
pound and they,
this disagreed.
Denied.
Oh my God,
idiot.
I bet you someone buys that though.
I'll bet I'll bet a dollar on it.
It says worth a dollar.
I got a dollar.
Let's start the bidding.
I mean,
that piece has history to.
It was the idiot who cut up.
You know what I'm saying?
I love it.
We've,
we've spent a lot of money on art.
Yeah.
But um,
maybe like a couple thousand dollars,
which you're basically paying for
someone's time and appreciation versus
you know,
$20,000,000
for a print.
I mean,
as a big difference.
I,
I appreciate art that I,
that I like and I'll,
I'll spend a thousand bucks,
a couple thousand bucks,
hundred thousand fucking suck.
A lot.
Depends.
Like this Guy Robert,
a Xavier has this huge Batman.
I love it.
It's amazing.
I mean that things,
I guess worth 100,000,
but it's like the size of this whole
back.
Yeah.
You kind of need.
He spent like 10,000
hours and like a whole house just for
that.
But anyway,
like there's some stuff like the gold,
the diamond skull.
What was that sold for?
Like 100 million,
$400,000,000.
How rich and board can you be?
A hundred million.
You could feed the whole continent of
Africa.
The non with the skull.
They're like,
they're like fix homelessness in our
city forever.
Now I'll take the school,
I'll take the school please.
They're like cure here.
Uh,
HIV and AIDS and all of Africa or one
diamond skull.
I'll take the school,
Howard stern had this great bit where he
went on the street that the Boston
bomber,
he was this handsome young,
like a Arab kid,
the Boston bomber,
and there was a lot of girls who are
like a talking about how cute he was and
so they went on the street with a
picture of Howard and a picture of the
Boston bomber and the like.
Which one would you rather date?
And everyone was picking the Boston
bomber over at Howard.
I love that.
So funny.
Rather data terrorists than our.
I don't think he was by the way,
just for the record.
Oh God.
What was he?
I think he was a Chechnyan.
I mean he was a Muslim.
He wasn't an Arab.
Correct.
Okay.
My bad.
I stand corrected.
I want to stand at my pulpit.
I want to say I am.
I apologize to all of my Arab brothers
out there who have been offended in this
unfortunate mischaracterization.
Not all,
not all Arabs are terrorists,
and that was not what I meant to imply
by any means of any stretch of
imagination.
He was a Muslim young man of Chechnyan
descent,
which I believe is.
Where's that Dan?
It's a region in southern Russia and
it's sort of an ongoing as it's been.
Great.
Thank you.
Thank you very much,
Dan,
for the clarification.
And uh,
please forgive me please.
And if you think that you need to write
an essay about my mistake here today and
expose me,
please you have my permission.
I made a grave error of judgment and I
give full permission to make a 30 minute
essay about it as is entirely warranted.
So apologies to everyone for that.
And a shout out to,
to the SAS right now,
a grease bands,
obese tourists from writing on donkeys.
I love.
It's fucking hilarious.
Here's our fat lady on a donkey.
Greece has banned fat tourists from
riding on donkeys after campaigners.
So the animals were being left with
spinal injuries.
Listen,
this isn't a century named grace.
We've been there.
It's a tiny little.
I never once had the urge to write a
dog.
It's not really even like a donkey
friendly.
No,
I don't really get that.
Um,
Australia,
if you look,
if you're fat,
you got to give up some,
you've kind of give some things up.
If you're a big fucking fatty and you're
going to break a donkey's back than
mean,
you know what I'm saying?
Like there was a Nathan for you about
the people on horses and he had to put
like weather balloons on him and shit.
Look,
don't have.
What's the weight limit?
How do they,
how do they define fat?
Because it just says fat.
Let's see how they define it.
The,
this,
these state,
a donkey giving tours.
Rides and salary should not carry any
load is heavier than 100 kilograms.
What does that convert to see sound like
a lot.
Two hundred and 20 pounds.
So unless you're extremely tall and
built,
if you're over 2100.
Wait,
what?
Yeah,
that's not a bad.
I too fat.
I'm like at one 95.
That's pretty close.
Yo.
I'm too fat for a donkey.
What the fuck?
Why do you need to ride a donkey?
A beast of burden is that now I just did
a complete one.
80 was writing these donkeys.
A little children.
Yeah.
I had a couple of hamburgers in my life,
but am I too fat to ride a donkey?
I don't think so.
They're just a little donkeys though.
They're not horses.
They're just trying to save them going
down the stairs so he can do the stairs.
Do some exercise.
No,
I need a donkey.
Ride the fucking kill this donkey
because I'm so fat.
I'm going to break its back.
Look down more.
You can see the stairs down more.
More.
Oh God.
You poor people taking the incognito fat
people on donkeys.
They blurted,
but a tiny bit.
You can still see that guy knows who he
is.
God.
He's not even enjoying himself.
That donkey will never have another
passenger and you're not even enjoying
yourself.
That dog is going to be put to sleep
after this and you're not even enjoying
yourself.
Wait,
this says,
yeah.
One hundred kilograms will gotta cut
him.
There's more.
You can go that down yourself.
Oh my God.
Wait.
We did do a donkey ride.
No,
we didn't in center in it.
Then we'd go up with donkeys on those
stairs are my fucking tripping balls.
No donkey rides.
Maybe I'm thinking of something else.
How did we get up to the hotel by car?
Like a same.
Yeah,
we had a car.
It's a normal place to take a donkey.
Those poor donkeys,
man.
God Damn poor motherfuckers fucked up
life.
Just falling fat.
Americans up and down a hill.
I love this store though.
So point.
Hmm.
Incredible stuff,
man.
Sixty minutes really stepped up.
Their game.
Dog is a mayor.
Oh,
we've got these fans submissions,
but it's already been two hours or hour
and a half short.
Wrap it up.
We could save it for next time.
This one's too funny.
I'm going to do this one on my hand at
guys.
Send your questions.
Comments,
uh,
essays,
video suggestions to podcasts at
[inaudible] productions.com.
I love it.
Um,
this one was so funny from Joey Lewis.
He says,
Hey Ethan.
Isla,
I listened to you're at number 87
podcasts where you mentioned how semen
can clog up the drain.
This was relevant to me because the
freshmen housing at my school,
thank God I don't live there.
Ken,
Ken's Shaw State,
they had to remove and replace the
plumbing for one of the buildings,
the whole entire building due to the
buildup of semen tangling with air.
There is a photo of the notice that the
university housing put up to reminds
just not to jerk off in the shower.
When you said there is a photo.
I almost.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know.
I have the same fear.
If you're not jerking off in the shower,
where are you jerking off,
but it's a communal shower.
You've got to jerk off responsibly.
Patrice O'neil had the Chris joke.
Every says,
I jerked off in the shower so many
times.
I'm surprised a little baby hasn't
crawled out your residence.
We have recently found several blockages
in plumbing system in university village
sweets mostly caused by human hair.
Let me set my water.
However,
over the last month,
we have found many of these blockages to
be caused by large quantities of what we
have now determined to be semen.
This is intolerable because semen is not
soluble in water.
It gets caught and filters and our sis
system and particularly susceptible.
This issue has cost the university
thousands of dollars to repair this far.
Thank God,
good thing you collect a lot of tuition
since stopped complaining.
It's warm out my semen,
though we know that though we know that
you must take care of your business.
We have never faced a situation of this
enormity before.
It is because of this.
Unfortunately,
that we must ask you to refrain from
masturbating in the shower.
May we those who wished to masturbate,
do so in the comfort of their own
bedroom and dispose of their discharge
appropriately.
I bet you 90 percent of the dudes
continue to jack off in the shop.
I knew,
and yet unlike [inaudible] no signature
though,
this guy should frame it.
No signature,
Joey.
That's the tough thing how you can't
guarantee that.
It's like you gotta stop me.
I'm jerking off in the shower that God
intended.
That's why school is so expensive,
so the fucking demon.
That's fine.
I had a communal shower and college boy.
It was cold sexual boys and girls shared
the same bathroom.
Yeah,
I know it was progressive Santa Cruz,
but there was all the.
So you would come out with a towel?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There wasn't naked people.
Yeah.
But like there's like four showers,
stalls next to each other with like a
curtain and private stall.
But yeah,
it was a cold wet,
but there was,
you could.
There was semen on the floor sometimes
guys.
Yeah.
There was a bathtub in there by the way.
Then nobody,
you.
But God forbid you were in the military.
Wasn't a coed there.
Are you fucking kidding?
Co?
Everything I know about the military is
from starship troopers,
so I don't know it.
It's the females.
We had our own like little area and the
mail having their own area.
Even the Western Wall is separated and
they're fucking fully clothed that the
US military is and coed.
Like I said,
starship troopers are eight.
Dan,
I'll never forget that scene and I saw
some titties that I didn't expect that I
still have a shower and I was like,
what the fuck?
Because I ended up,
I was like 13,
so if somebody like looked at me,
pop a boner and it's like,
how do they shower with her and they
don't all have fat boners right now.
Remember when you're 13 and like you
tend,
you hit a speed bump on the bus a little
too fast.
You pop a boner,
tuck it under the belt,
you get really good at the uh,
the Bass,
uh,
the backpack masking method.
Yeah.
Was checking something in your backpack?
I tucked it under the belt most of the
time,
but sometimes because you have to kind
of maneuver for that.
And Yeah,
a lot of tucking and grabbing.
So the backpack is definitely a god
send.
It's one of the two options.
I don't think there's anything else.
Is there anything else in or Zach,
is there another way that you guys
concealed boners rarely ever get them at
school,
but as soon as I got home and was like
sitting on the toilet when I was 13,
that was it.
What,
what?
You pop a bony on the toilet because
it's like your space,
like do your business jerk off.
Yeah.
This is what I'm saying.
You didn't read the question.
Where else have you mentioned to me
that.
So you would shit and jerk off?
Uh,
yes sir.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Would you check off after you shit?
Uh,
yeah.
Well it really depends how big the shape
is.
Shit,
while jerking off.
Always separate.
I don't know if that's possible,
but you know,
like it was either one before the other.
So you sit there still do flush the bulb
before he check off.
Like you said over the shit.
I can't jerk off on this shit and the
flush and then you've still stinks.
Probably though have like a smell.
I smell my own farts.
I'm a minute.
I love it.
Love it.
Yeah.
You wouldn't admit it.
You don't like to smell your own parts?
Not even a little bit.
You're not intrigued.
No.
Not intrigued.
At least interested.
Interested in what?
The smell.
No,
fucking liar.
That's like a biological fact that
people liked the smell,
their own fars like,
like they enjoy.
I think so you'd think Dan,
do you like the smell it?
I'm sorry.
I can't.
Sorry,
you started by saying it's a fact and
then you finished with.
I think so.
I was.
I think this is another debate.
I think people like the smell,
but I will.
I will give you that.
Kind of tolerate it for sure.
For sure.
I her,
I swear to God.
You smell it and enjoy it.
You,
Dave,
you breathe deeply on it.
You're just doing a movie.
I am not.
I liked the small amount of parks.
There's a lot of people out there that
said,
I agree.
So this is another one of these things
mean to explore.
I'm being genuine by the way.
I'm serious.
Why would I admit to that?
But like why would I lie about liking
the spelman being controversial?
I'm not eva wants desperately,
not the believer.
This is what I'm hearing.
Um,
there was another one somebody asked,
um,
and the spirit of all these
conversations id zed,
zed zed slur asked,
I was always convinced everyone picks
their nose picking her nose,
ventilates it effectively and enables
you to breathe much easier for the more
scraping,
a nice dry chunk of snot out of your
nose is the best feeling ever.
To me it seems like a basic human
necessity.
But maybe those are just my own habits.
Ever since you started these types of
conversation on your podcast,
I started doubting my judgment on what's
normal and what is not more and more.
So.
Do you pick your nose?
If so,
which finger do use also?
I'm pretty sure there are people who
even eat their burger.
I'm not sure whether it is only kids or
adults to personally.
I always found it gross so I never did.
Do you?
So,
um,
we're discussing taboo.
We're breaking apart tonight on 60
minutes.
I think everyone picks their nose,
but there's certain levels to it.
Like if I'm in the shower,
like I find it gross.
So if I'm in the shower,
that's a good place to pick my nose,
but generally I'll try to use a tissue
or something just because I don't.
I just think it's kind of gross
personally.
But I think everyone picks their nose.
I tell you what's grocer that I've seen
people do.
I guess you're just walking with
somebody on the street and just out a
nowhere without saying anything.
Oh my fucking.
The worst is the worst.
You're just having a conversation and
make conversation.
Should Sean Balog does that?
I'm like,
what the fuck are you calling?
Whatever.
He doesn't care.
And then they won't come out.
So they'll go on the street with
shredder the other day and someone just
walking across the street from me and
they go,
why would you do that in sight of
another human being a lunatic.
Some people think that's normal.
That's fucking wild.
Shit.
Shit's crazy.
So picking the nose,
I think.
I agree.
Eating boogers is fucked up.
If you're under the age of eight,
you need to plug in.
Can Weirdo over.
But yeah,
actually,
you know what?
I shouldn't say I don't want to.
I never did it as my personal
preference.
I seen some friends where I look over
and they're like trying to like low key.
They're bugs when I was.
Now I know people do that.
I don't want to shame booger eaters
because we're.
We're getting out there,
we're putting it all out there.
So I think I do think there's a large
percentage of adults eat their burgers
and secret.
The idea to me is frankly repulsive.
Why?
I don't think Zachary fee and then
anything is possible.
People like it.
I don't know.
It's like smelling your own far to me.
That makes sense.
But eating a burger makes me want to
fucking die.
He enter.
Zach,
I have to ask for posterity.
Do any of you guys pick your nose or eat
your books?
I would rather lick dog poop.
Then wonder what about your own Burger?
Absolutely not disgusting.
No,
never year and it's his own books only
gets the skepticism came into dry too
fast.
So anyway,
that was interesting conversation.
I'm just.
That's about it.
I know about dog becomes mares.
That's something interesting or no dog
became a mayor.
That's it.
There you go.
That's just what,
you know,
there's this whole story about a dog is
getting reelected as mayor and what it
made me think about is what does this
say about the job,
mayor?
I stopped the bullying the video.
Say like you did good.
Like what does that mean?
He's a good boy.
Being the mayors of serious job.
Like you get paid like you have
responsibilities.
Like what does this say about all
government job?
I think it was the mayor of La is a
serious job.
Yeah.
But uh,
I think in,
in smaller towns,
the mayor is like a ceremonial thing,
like the city council really run shit.
And then the mayor,
I know this completely from parks and
rec.
So take this all with everything I know
is based off your shows and the movies,
all the knowledge question.
Um,
and they're,
you know what they're said it cost a
dollar to vote for the mayor.
I was like,
well,
let's wait.
Really?
No.
Or to run human know about dollar volt.
Probably not that serious of an
election.
Then it costs to vote.
That's what I recall from the video.
We're not going to watch.
All right.
That's enough of this.
Thank you everyone who watched.
Thank you everyone who listened.
Thank you everyone who enjoyed.
I hope you're having a blessed at
Friday.
Hope you have a blessed weekend.
Thank you to everyone who's taking notes
diligently right now to cast their essay
on a Swedish reproductions and how I've
changed,
which is true.
I have changed.
And so there's definitely something
there.
How I've compromised my morals for
money.
That's a popular one.
There's evidence there you can pull from
and um,
yeah,
there's a lot there.
So I wish you all the best with your
essay and we all look forward to walk.
So guys,
thank you all.
And of course using this clip and be
using this club and be like,
look how he doesn't take criticism.
Look how he makes fun of the fact that
he's just a shill.
I look forward to that as well and I,
and I think if we're taking everything
into consideration,
my dear friends have a blessing.
Bless and weekend.
Thank you all so much and thank you all
for enjoying our new video.
That meant a lot.
It was very nice to see.
Yeah,
felt good.
It was a very wholesome experience day.
Very happy thoughts and,
and I'll see you hopefully a lot of you
tomorrow at Ripon dip at our little meet
and greet.
I'm looking forward to all of that and
so much more.
He was pregnant.
We had a whole thing about.
We had a whole thing about food.
You can eat deli meats.
You've got nine months to talk about it.
You can't eat deli meats.
I was like,
if isla can eat deli meats when she was
pregnant,
we all should not be eating delegates.
That's freaky.
You know what I'm saying?
But that's not how it works.
It's not just.
It's sensitive to the.
To the little.
The little people have a baby that it is
right now.
Boucher songs almost over.
Oh,
we better go.
All right guys,
thank you all for watching.
Have a blessed weekend.
Love you,
appreciate you and we'll see you next
time.
Thank you so much.